[Music]
my 21 year old son about a month ago
suffered a mental breakdown
and uh if i if i break my ankle doctor i
go to the er and i get it fixed i get a
cast on if i break something in my brain
no one seems to know how to
how to help you or help my son
yo yo yo what up this is john with the
dr john dolone show
so glad that you're with us
hey this weekend i was
in
i mean there's
the woods and then there's backwoods and
then there's the places behind those
woods
in the middle of the country is where
i'll tell you and um my family and i
went there to visit some friends who
literally live in a log cabin we love
them
and it's kind of a sanctuary for us and
uh
we were there and we went to a fireworks
show and
with this community a small community
and um
we're sitting on a blanket dude i've got
bug bites in places i did not know you
could get bug bites
and uh all of you people who are like
i'm just gonna get my whatever in my go
bags and go to the woods
you'll die from bugs just so you know
you won't you'll
take fewer guns and knives and take more
off
because the battle will be won with who
can who can take the bug bites but
that's that's a digression
so i'm in sitting on a blanket and
there's a turtle race and a watermelon
eating contest i mean exactly how you
think it would be
uh
and lovely lovely people and somebody's
so kind i won't say their name here
was just started telling me a story
about how they've had multiple people
pass away in their family this year
and how this show has been helpful to a
couple of their family members as
they're navigating boundaries and i'm
not responding to this text thread and
i'm staying out of this and so
dude it just it it
it's awesome and that's because of you
all who listen to this show and pass it
along to your friends and then they pass
it to their sister or their brother or
their cousin when somebody passed away
i just want to say personally um
way back in the woods where there's
lovely lovely lovely people
um
where we're going we don't need roads
there
as people listening to show and um
doing the hard work of loving each other
anyway and
and uh making some changes in their
personal lives and their marriages and
in their homes and in their in the mess
messiness of life so thank you so much
keep passing it along
um if you're a review person i've kind
of take like i don't do reviews just as
like my way of sticking it to the man
which is such a lame way to stick it to
the man
um but if you're a review person leave a
good review and i'd be really grateful
and if you have a negative review send
it to um kelly's personal cell number
and i'll post that on instagram later on
today all right let's go straight to uh
the let's go to eddie in austin texas
what's up eddie
uh yes hi hi doctor thank you for taking
my call of course brother how are you
man well
well not well i'm not a man of many
words but
right now this is a tough one for for me
my wife my family my 21 year old son
about a month ago suffered a
mental breakdown
and uh
so um
quickly i i uh
i found out that this mental health
system is it's really it's really
difficult to navigate um yes to help my
son it's a mess
yeah like hold on hold on a second eddie
um
number one i'm gonna stop right there
thank you for calling
it's a hard call to make
okay so um the the number of dads i've
sat with in your exact seat i can't
count them there's been a lot and i know
this is a hard hard moment to say it out
loud and i want to just want to applaud
your bravery okay it's hard
very very hard
um when you say your son had a mental
breakdown what does that mean what
happened
well we found out he had been a
he was on his own uh living in san
antonio okay
he was he had a steady income job
became a realtor
he left that steady income job
to go 100
commission
it was hard he was he's a he's a he's a
young man that he's a hard worker
he he he has no dad he invests his money
and all of a sudden he oh well
he he uh
he just started
having problems with
with his memory
and he started
getting really paranoid about things
yeah
he seemed to lose touch of
reality at times
and uh found out that he had a month
this happened a month about a month ago
found out that
before that a month before that he had
quit smoking marijuana yet he was a
daily user
and uh
also a cbd
user which i didn't know what that was
until now
and uh
so that that that's what happened so he
couldn't function he he
we brought him home with us
and we you know we were if i if i break
my ankle doctor i go to the er and i get
it fixed i get a cast on if i break
something in my brain
[Applause]
no one no one seems to know how to
how to help you help my son yeah
so
i know it's not that easy it's
complicated but it's complicated but it
it is that easy and it is that
complicated so it's both and okay and
the the challenge here is to not lean
into the despair part
okay yeah and at the same time
you gotta lean into the grief part and
we'll get to that but real quick
often
um by the way i have zero none
um i've no issues with with cbd i
haven't seen any sort of studies
whatsoever that suggests that's in that
that
has any sort of
negative effects on somebody okay it is
a hemp derivative but i that doesn't
bother me
it it i would say
my students used to and and friends kids
especially would go i would always tell
people don't buy health products at a
gas station that's never the place to
get that stuff right um but that didn't
bother me
my question for you about the hemp i
mean about cbd about marijuana often
when people feel themselves starting to
slowly unspool
that helps or that's where they go they
end up there they might drink they might
they starting to look for ways to tamp
down
an increasingly
loud volatile brain
and also i've heard recently in the past
few years people
just smoke and weed with their buddies
and it's got fentanyl in it and they
literally cook their brain and so my
question for you is
is
any sort of is dr any doctor said this
is a a
chemical induced issue or
actually the marijuana was your son
trying to self-medicate a
um a pretty quickly devolving
psychological state
well he he was he was uh smoking
marijuana so that he can calm down
okay okay he had he had a he had a lot
of stress and he said you know he would
he would use it to go to sleep and to
function and focus okay all right um i i
did i did take him recently to a mental
clinic uh that is
tied to
ut health center okay and nurse
practitioner under a
psychiatrist has diagnosed him with
substance induced
psychosis okay
and general and and general anxiety
disorder okay
um other other places
i met him at mhmr they
they diagnosed him with severe
depression
but again
in some places since he's 21
they don't let the you know the parents
go in and yeah
they don't see the other things that
then they only hear what he he tells
them right
sometimes you know that's not the full
picture gotcha
okay so
do me a favor
and take a huge deep breath
and hold it
okay as deep as your lungs can hold
and let it out
all right okay
so
if you have um substance abuse
induced psychosis
or extreme anxiety to the point
that um
your body's rattling
or you have um severe depression
i can see i can see a place where these
are all on some sort of similar trend
line let me give you some peace of mind
that they didn't both come back and say
your son's got something like
schizophrenia
okay
you're talking about two very different
paths forward
okay
and so
um
i'm not saying this to belittle my
friends and community members who've got
family members with schizophrenia what
i'm saying is if i took my son in i
would much rather a diagnostic out of
the gate of he smoked so much weed he
right he rattled his body up okay
um or he's so anxious he took a job and
he put himself in a situation where his
body said hey i'm out or he's been
pushing and pushing and pushing and
pushing and pushing
and he's got some childhood traumas etc
and he's ended up very very depressed
i would much rather walk that road with
my son
than
get a diagnosis of schizophrenia
okay like a
a psychiatric illness due to brain
lesions or brain functioning does that
make sense
yeah it does okay so i'm trying to give
you a light here okay
thank you yeah
um
i can i can ask you something
you can ask me anything you want to you
got it um
should i keep should i keep um you know
i i quickly found out that there's other
mental health clinics that i can take
him
cost a lot of money would cost us a lot
of our life savings to take him
um should i should i go that route to
get the the right diagnosis if to be
sure and you know
so that i can
you know move forward with this i don't
know what
right now
what when you went to the
the ut system and you met with the the
psychiatrist or the the psychiatric
nurse practitioner did they give you a
plan of of action moving forward
or did they just write you a script and
send you out the door they
they they do they they gave me they gave
him uh you know the prescription
medicine to take as needed um he does
follow up he's gonna follow up with a
therapist okay
um
he he is much better
than he was with when this crisis event
happened to him you know he's doing a
little bit better he he wants he lives
in san antonio and we have actually a
family property there and he's been
staying there okay
by himself i don't know that's healthy
for him
um
you know he's not working i'm helping
him uh
at um
you know
that's another issue that you know that
that where my wife and i have been
confident
sure not knowing you know
how to how to move forward with it
so let me tell you what i would do in
your situation okay
number one um
what the
psychiatrist gave you the the
psychiatric mp gave you
is a very standard treatment of care
okay
okay they gave him some medicine to and
the fact that she said as needed
would give me another level of relief
that sounds like and again i'm not there
so i'm speaking off the cuff here okay
but it sounds episodic
meaning this is not indicative of if you
keep pressing the same way we were
pressing yes eventually we're gonna have
some the if we keep driving the car the
way we were driving it eventually this
engine's gonna stop right
but yeah what she's saying is
hey take this gas treatment as if you
hear knocks and pings
and you got to drive safer and by the
way we're going to
um we're going to do some things to help
along the way so that's number one the
next thing would be is you need to get
some new driving lessons okay
and
the what the data tells me is
research is very clear that
therapy plus the medication is the magic
there okay
and i've got my own opinions on that
they're not important right now
i think getting your son
um in with a good therapist right now is
really really important
and so if i'm gonna i've spent money
somewhere and again this is just me
talking if i'm gonna spend money in my
life somewhere i'm not gonna go chase a
third and a fourth and a fifth diagnosis
i'm just not
i'm gonna get off of youtube
okay right i'm gonna go get with a
good
counselor and lucky luckily you're in an
area you're in that area between austin
and san antonio there's some great
practitioners there
okay of all different flavors and here's
what the
the scholarship tells us doesn't matter
the flavor as much as it matters the
relationship between the therapist and
the in the client okay
correct what does that mean find a place
where your son feels comfortable where
he can go tell the truth
okay
that's going to be more important than
is it an mft or a psychologist or say
the psychiatrist does the medical stuff
um
i want you to go find help him find a
good counselor okay
now here's really important
if i'm you
and he's willing to
do the work to get well
i would probably ask my son i give him
the option to come live with me for six
months and get things lined back up
i am a person who believes that
loneliness and isolation is one of the
chief drivers of anxiety
okay and so that idea that i'm on my own
i'm on my own i'm on my own our bodies
are simply not designed to exist that
way they're just not um and this is
thousands of years old we're just not
wired to live that way
and
um so i would give him the option and
that option would come with some
stipulations you got you can't miss
counseling
um
we're gonna help out x and we're going
to help out with why but you got to get
a job you got to have some sort of
purpose you got to have some reason for
to get up and go
which is the little wins which helps in
both depression and it helps in in
anxiety okay
and yeah we're going to have some
weekly check-ins just dad and son going
to breakfast
talking about talking about the astros
right i mean we're going to do some
we're going to re-do human stuff
not about the diagnosis and how you're
feeling and give me a one-to-ten scale
that's for him and the counselor we're
going to start doing life
you get what i'm saying
yeah
really yeah um and so that i mean
if i'm in your exact situation that's
that's the path i would take and he
could he's 21 he could tell me to screw
off
he could tell me i'm not coming home
um he could tell me no i'm going to keep
i'm going to keep hammering away at this
job i'm going to keep doing it he's 21
he can do that the other thing you can
do here is also
um he doesn't have to do this
but you can ask for a release from his
psychiatrist or his counselor and if
you're paying for it that might be part
of it unless he's not going to go
the other thing is you can always give
information one way to a counselor
and every therapist i know really
welcomes that information
meaning if he gets a therapist or
psychiatrist or something you can send
them an email of hey he was abused as a
child him and his my
his mom gotten fights and like whatever
the history you think you need that that
therapist needs to know you're welcome
to send that
sure okay he didn't find the release
okay great
yes i do have that access to that and
what what about when he it
he's you know he is taking medicine as
needed and but he does want to take that
cbd is that
okay or is that
that's between him and his doctor quite
honestly um
i know people that were highly anxious
and
i can only attribute it to cbd helping
reset the
uh
anxiety response
there's a whole chemical pathway there
um and then i've i've talked to
practitioners who say dude we see little
to no
help
okay
uh it makes it worse though
i've not seen that i've never seen that
again that's a question for him
outside of it yeah i've never seen any
sort of data or any sort of personal
experience or any sort of
um if it helps you i take i take cbd i
take a clinical grade um i used to take
it quite regularly when i was struggling
anxiety and now i take it very sparingly
okay i've never seen any sort of
connectivity between
cbd and psychosis
maybe if you took a ton of it or
something
um i also don't smoke um
so i'm not gonna smoke anything either
and by the way i get it from a
highly reputable clinical great company
i don't get it from a gas station
okay
okay so that's just my per that's just
my personal thing what i would strongly
recommend though is have that
conversation with the psychiatric mp
and if he or she says no then absolutely
cut it off because everybody's different
and he may need a time to reset his
reset himself
okay okay but you have some have some
peace there
um thank you
is there some things in his history in
his past that you're worried about
or is this just a matter of a young kid
getting out on the zone and trying to
hit the gas too hard and then got to
smoking a lot a lot a lot not sleeping
very much and living off red bull and
monster energy drinks and all of a
sudden just spun out i i i think i think
he had some stressors that i just you
know that came about um that have that
contributed to this
um
where he used to work
he had a he was a property manager of uh
you know a real estate company
and he had to he he got a call that he
had to go to some apartment complex or
whatever to
ask about to
move their car because they were parked
in the right spot
got a gun pulled up on him
um
is
another thing that he found out was
recently his
girlfriend had an abortion he's pro-life
okay so he's dealing with a lot of
trauma
trauma
yeah
i have asked him what
he's like just being on his own was hard
for him and he he's not one to ask for
help i said why
why don't you ever come to me and ask
for help i mean his truck broke down and
so i think
a lot of things just bottled up and so
hey
let me give you a a tool okay
um yeah
often when somebody's hurting
or when somebody's being abused or when
somebody any kind of thing like that
we go to them and our first thought is
dude why didn't you tell me i would have
stood arm-in-arm with you i would have
thrown the first punch why didn't you
tell them to say anything
right here's the here's the response
i've seen in my own life and in those i
walk with and work with in their life
that has become more a more effective
entry point into that conversation
especially between fathers and sons
son i'm sorry that i didn't give you a
picture of what asking for help looks
like
either you're a person who asks for help
a lot
and your son never saw that
or
you model those same things
and you're a good texan who just figures
it out
and when you don't figure it out you
crack another beer and then you figure
it out the next day right and
what i have found is asking somebody why
didn't you
simply adds to the list of things
that they it fee their body responds as
a it's a fracture in our relationship
which is going to sound those alarms
even louder
the entry point being dude i'm so sorry
i didn't give you a picture of what this
looks like that's on me
here's my commitment moving forward
will you make that commitment with me
that's that's that's a much different
entry point because that's saying we're
going to do this together not why didn't
you screw this up
or why did you screw this up
and just for the the dad's listening out
there the other day i was um driving
with my son and i was having a
relatively hard conversation
in the conversation was being had with
me
with a
the number one he's one of the top
researchers in the planet in his
particular thing i'm struggling with a
um i'm trying to get something worked
out with my physiology with my diet and
it's not working the way i wanted it to
work and it's frustrating for me
and i was talking to him on the phone
and my son was just sitting there
and i thought you know what he needs to
hear
another expert telling his dad
that his dad's
ways to try to hack the system are not
working and he needs to just follow the
plan so i put on speakerphone
and this guy's a great human being funny
and also has given it to me a little
give me the like hey you got to do this
right but i wanted my son to hear that
and then afterwards i said hey
i know you know this but i call people
to help with coaching too because i need
to get help too
and he's like i know dad i know and i
said no no i need you to hear that i was
talking to the number one person in the
country on this topic
and i still was acting as though i was
smarter than him and this is him setting
me straight as as a friend
and so i let him listen to that because
i want him to have a picture of what
asking for help looks like as he gets
older okay but
i would start that way with my son eddie
okay
thank you um i would trust that the
system that you've mentioned is good
they've got a great reputation i would
trust that um the nurse practitioner i
would trust the
path she gave you forward or he gave you
forward i would get a counselor or psych
a psychologist in your area
and i would ask give my son permission
to come home for six months come on for
nine months and here's the thing it's
helpful for everybody to put a time
limit on that
you don't have to stick to the time
limit
but if you ask a 21 year old once you
come on home
you can look up and it's three years and
you don't like each other anymore and
there's a whole mess or it could feel
like dude i'm going to fail your no no
we're just going on for six months come
on for six months and let's see if we
can get this thing dialed in i'll start
having breakfast with my son and um i
need to have some healing too and so
let's start doing this together and then
we'll reevaluate in five and a half
months and we'll see what comes next it
might be another six months after that
maybe that's it right enough to get him
on get his feet underneath him
and he's got to deal with trauma the
loss
he's gonna have to deal with the fear of
getting a gun pulled down he's got to
deal with all that stuff and that's what
a counselor is going to help him walk
through
and based on the limited stuff you told
me it sounds like his body had enough
there was no margin because the way he
was living um there was no margin here
no margin there no margin no margin no
margin and then somebody pulled a gun on
him
and then his girlfriend violated a core
value of his right and and really hurt
him deeply and and we could go on and on
and on
all i have to say is
your son's not broken
he's not dysfunctional and he's not lost
this is a great time to hit control
delete on your relationship with your
son your wife's relationship with her
son and to say hey let's lean into
connectivity into relationship
let's follow what the doctors say let's
be about healing and as someone who has
struggled mightily with anxiety i want
you to know on the other side of it
there's light and there's a lot of
laughter and there's a lot of joy
and
there's good stuff it's worth it's worth
the effort thank you so much for your
bravery and for uh being vulnerable
eddie i'm grateful for you we'll be
right back
hey john dolone here and people i'm
getting fired up it's finally warmer
outside and it's starting to stay light
longer and you should be spending more
time outside going for a run playing
with your kids at the park or just doing
a bunch of yard work i know that i'm
doing all those things but when you're
running hard you must remember to
recharge your body with a good night's
sleep and that starts with a quality
mattress like a dream cloud
dream cloud's combination of gel memory
foam and coil technology keeps you
comfortable all
night long and that means you can go all
out all day because you're actually
getting solid restful sleep at night
time right now dream cloud is offering
their biggest deal ever exclusively for
our listeners when you buy a dream cloud
mattress you get 499 dollars in sleep
accessories plus an additional 250
discount that's 749 dollars in
accessories and savings start getting
the rest your body needs visit
dreamcloudsleep.com and enter promo code
deloney to get your new mattress and 749
in savings today
all right we're back let's go to brianna
in columbus what's up brianna
hello
how are we doing
i'm doing pretty good how are you
we are just figuring it out every day
right
so what's up absolutely
um okay so my question is
how much should you talk to your spouse
about work oh no how much should you
share nothing
never are you crazy
what uh what's the tell me some more
about what you're asking okay so um
about three years ago we moved 12 hours
away from our everything we knew
for his job okay can we stop right here
you're gonna have to let that resentment
go
i don't know what comes after this but
you'll have no peace in your home or in
your marriage and if you've got kids in
your parenting unless you let that piece
go
or y'all move back
is that cool
absolutely you're definitely right about
that um we are moving back in a few
months
you are moving back all right so we're
moving back
can i ask you why are you moving back
it was only supposed to be a temporary
thing um he they opened a new location
needed someone who knew the company to
come and manage it for a little bit so
they kind of got up and going okay and
it turned into a couple of years
yeah it was originally going to be two
to three years so we're out a little
longer than three years
okay have you hated it the whole time
uh 80 of the time
why did you hate it
i
was very i have a very close family okay
and i um
really struggled
figuring out
how to
make connection with other people
that i didn't already know
at least a little bit
or that didn't know me
gotcha
so yeah that was a that was definitely a
struggle for a long time
um and i went to work at the same place
that he worked um because i needed a job
and didn't know where to get a job at
um and we live on the property
oh jeez
so
i most of my life is
revolved around
one thing and that is
with the place that he works now i don't
work there at the moment i work
somewhere else
and have
been able to find friends there and
connection there
but sometimes it feels like my entire
life is consumed
by the place that he works why is it
consumed
um
i
i
worked there for a long time i started
my day there i ended my day there and
even though uh you know we come home and
it's not you know we're not clocked in
i'm not at work i
struggle a lot to
turn that off in my mind and i still
have a hard time with that even though i
don't work there anymore
like i have a saying when i get off of
work that i have to tell myself so that
my brain will
transition and i can just go home and be
who i am there and i'm not you know
clocked in anymore i'm not working i'm
not what is it one of the things that
happened what's it the things that
you're
you're plugged into is it like is it the
gossip and like who you know people
someone slept with dan again i mean is
it that or is it
are you dialed into the
like the business function and and how
we're like we're making money like what
are you missing
um
for him
or for the place where he works i
think that it's more so that i
just want to make sure that everything's
still okay
no one thinks he's horrible why
that seems like an incredible burden to
to carry especially when you can do
nothing about it
i would agree with that
um let me let me back out a little bit
um because i think this is all connected
so follow me on a train of thought here
okay absolutely um
so you you left
yes
your close-knit family
and there was an awkward period where
you weren't there anymore and you
weren't in the know and you weren't in
the in the figuring it all out right
yeah
and you found yourself
on an island somewhere 12 hours away or
as you say it 12 hours away right so
really far away
a half of a day away
it's only a day
annie no i won't do that that's 24 hours
so it's not 12.
so you find yourself 12 hours away
and then there's this decision point
there's this moment
i don't know anybody here and i'm
completely disconnected here
i can have one of two choices
i can
just go be weird and i can go be awkward
and i can go find people and try to be
awkward with them and be like hey i'm
new to town and this is weird and you
all want to go get
you know sandwiches or do you want to go
get coffee or i'm having a barbecue
y'all are coming to my house and you
bring the weird desserts because this is
what you all do 12 hours away from
everything i know
and in that process you have no you
don't know the skills you don't know any
of the of the lingo you don't know the
culture
but you're figuring it out along the way
and the key is you're you're stumbling
and tripping and falling
forward with other people
the other decision
is i'm just gonna sit here and watch
netflix and be pissed off for three
years
and i'm gonna get a job and get really
embedded into my little world
and if i pull that same thread over here
you went to work with your husband in
the same exact place which hey put food
on the table and give you something to
do probably wasn't the best thing
globally but it is what it is it
happened
and
then you laughed
for whatever reason
probably best for your marriage and all
things
but instead of now making a new place
you put a an anchor into that place
and you're trying to control things that
backwards again
and instead of living in the place that
you are
you're trying to control places that
you've been
see what i'm saying
yeah and so my challenge to you is like
so to answer your question how do you
stop then you just stop
that sounds so ridiculous
um here's what it looks like in real
life in real real life
um
i'm just going to give you a personal
example because i did this yesterday
there's a
i work with university officials behind
closed doors and kind of walk they you
know we talk and help each other through
problems and things and challenges
um one i gave a clear
do not do this thing
and that person wouldn't do that thing
and i'm beginning to hear about it
across the country
and
i was with a group of people yesterday
and i was like i'm telling you i said
don't do this thing and then while i'm
saying this out loud number one i'm
gossiping about somebody which is
completely stupid it's just to lift me
up which is so lame
and b
i
like
i stop myself it's like why do you care
you don't go to that school your kids
don't go to that school you have no
vested interest like what are you doing
and i literally stopped mid-sentence and
just trailed off the conversation in an
awkward way and luckily i'm so awkward
most of the time nobody did nobody
thought twice about it
here's what it looks like in real time
for you the moment you're like well hey
is so
nope
not gonna do that
and saying to yourself i literally don't
care
and i want you to practice that
and then more importantly i want you to
practice having something else to talk
about something else of interest to you
something else that you're working on or
pretending to get involved in or
practicing you see what i'm saying
yeah
absolutely tell me why that's tell me if
that's hard
i know it is and i know i'm making it
sound so easy but tell me
like
because it is super hard but it's also
really simple
yeah
um
i'm not really i don't know that i know
the answer to that question um
besides that this
i feel like
that i was drowning in the ocean and
this little big tiny boat
came and grabbed me
and now this boat's sinking but because
it saved my life the first time i'm
still holding on to it instead of
getting on a different boat gotcha if
that makes sense yes
unpack drowning for me
what does that actually mean was it that
you were lost at sea because you left
everything you knew and came to a new
city in a new state in a new part of the
country
you always say you go with you
and that is true for me when we moved
here i had to face
the things that i needed to take care of
and that i needed to do differently
and
that has been a long
scary process for me that i have never
seen modeled for me awesome um did you
do it so
i did i'm still doing it and i'm never
gonna stop doing it it's been incredible
so a lot of the time it felt like i was
just gonna go all the way under and i
was never gonna climb back out
um
but you did yeah
but it did did you do it with other
people
yes
and those times you thought you were
going under
you realized that other people are
holding you up
which is why i'm always so adamant about
people getting to other people you just
described in very clear terms bravery
that's courage
sorry
i'm really really proud of you
so yes
understand this so you go with you
that's like a little saying i throw
around all the time
um i'm gonna try to make a saying out of
what i'm about to say here i'm not gonna
try to make it i'm trying to make a cool
little thing that i could put on the
internets but i don't know i'm not good
at that
um
what's the right way to say this
just because it hurts doesn't mean it's
wrong
and my guess is you're going to look
back on these three years
where you had to figure out who you were
and what you were made of and the skills
you were missing you've known it for a
long time but you got to stay in a
regular rhythm and routine
and when you're with family a lot they
keep you in your place you know what i
mean yeah my sister's four years older
than me and my brother's five years
younger than me and we all get together
and we go right back to being older
sister middle middle kid younger brother
right
and when you untether all that
12 hours away
when you do that then
suddenly you have you you've known for a
long time and here you are dealing with
it and here's the thing when you go home
people are going to recognize you
yeah and it's gonna be real easy to go
back to old brianna
yeah and that's
that's a fear i've been working through
yeah
so let me let me tell you something and
one of the things i think that the
modern mental health community of which
i'm a part of i'm at fault here too
we haven't done a good job
of
let me say this
we have communicated to people that
mental health and wellness is just
getting the right thoughts in the right
order
and if you can just think the right
things in the right order everything is
quote unquote gonna be okay
and so there is an important part to
think about this coming as you're
heading home
and the work you've done
and the new skills you've picked up and
then brianna that now stands six inches
taller than the one who went 12 hours
away right
[Music]
but i want to add something to it the
the modern mental health community is
left out is you're gonna have to do
different things
you're gonna have to hang out with
different people and maybe even live in
a different part of the town
and you're gonna have to say no to
things
and you're not just gonna go right back
to the same thursday night dinners at
ma's house or whatever because that's
the night that you and your husband have
right whatever y'all gonna do
but you're gonna have to create a new
world and live into it and that's going
to be really insulting to the people who
expect you to come back and be the
brianna that they
have created in their own mind
yeah right i i absolutely agree with
that does your husband is he in support
of you
a million times over
does he love
um brianna 2.0
yeah
absolutely is he scared about you going
back to being you when you get home
um
i would think that would be a little bit
of a fear for him um have you asked him
he would
i don't think i've asked him that way
ask him that way
okay
because my guess is it's not just it's
just a little fear i bet it's a big one
and it would be really fun exercise for
y'all
to create a world to like engineer a new
environment moving forward and say
here's the magic question who are we
going to be
the day we land back at home
who are we going to be
and when we say who we're going to be
we're going to be fun we're going to be
spontaneous we're going to be laughing
we're going to keep our our weekly movie
night so we're going to keep our
random uh
thanksgiving full of misfits we're we're
going to keep these these parts of
ourselves and that's going to inform the
things that you're not going to
do
the phone is still getting put away at
eight o'clock at night so i'm not
responding to every family member
emergency text because they're not all
emergencies and i don't wanna right i'm
gonna begin to create this world and
then i'm gonna live into it it's gonna
be fantastic
hear me say i'm so proud of you
recreate this world together that you're
going home to
to answer your original original
question about how much should we talk
about work every couple's different i've
learned that the
less the better
and in my house we set some pretty
strong boundaries and so i will say
things like can i talk about a thing
that happened at work today and my wife
will say do you want a solution you want
me just to listen
and i will say i need to need you to
listen and she'll say great go for it
um by setting up the setting up the
conversation it keeps her from just
becoming my trash bin and me coming home
and just dumping crap on her all day
long every day so i structure the
conversations like i want to tell you
something about work
normally i say
i'm struggling with
feeling like i'm not doing anything
worth a crap or i'm struggling with a
hard conversation i have to have it work
that's less about work and that's about
me and she wants to hear about that
she does not want to hear about the
gossip and i don't want to talk about it
she doesn't want to hear about what's
the what's the you know the
i don't know the
profit reporter she don't hear about
that she wants to know if her paycheck's
going to change right
but i think going home and using work as
a living soap opera to prop up two
people having a conversation with one
another is a terrible terrible way to
live
create your own life
with your own joys and your own hard
stuff
and talk about those things
and if you leave a job
leave it all the way
leave it all the way thank you so much
for your bravery brown i'm proud of you
i'm really proud of you i can't wait to
see what happens next we'll be right
back
hey what's up deloney here i've got a
word from our sponsor betterhelp i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work
but burnout can happen at any area of
our lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelphelp.com
all right we're back let's take unimas
let's go back to tejas and talk to
samantha what's up samantha
hello
hello
how are we doing how's it going
i'm good and you
yes i'm good very cool what's up
okay so my original question has changed
a little bit okay um i sent that
question on a really rough day and i've
since then had a really great
conversation with my husband walk me
through your original question
okay so it was basically asking for
practical tips on
how to
trust my husband after a pornography
addiction okay all right
um
sort of i mean that's not solved
so
excellent all right so on to the next
question what's the next question okay
so
um so basically i still okay so it's
been about a year and a half since he's
been clean from looking at anything okay
um and so but i still struggle with my
body image and so i'm kind of looking
for like tips or suggestions on how to
deal with that or increase positivity
with that um
and then i also
just wanted to mention that i feel like
since
all of it happened i've kind of lost um
it's been more than a year and a half
since it came out
and there was also some like from when
we dated and so
it's been like years
of kind of struggling with this off and
on
um
so i i feel like somewhere along the way
i lost like the fun part of me
and i feel like it probably has to do
with that um and i don't really know how
to get that back
so i know that's a lot so whatever we
get to is fine it'll all be beneficial
no that's good i
um
let me see here
so this is a hard conversation to have
and here's why
um
the only
part of the conversation i can have is
with you because he's not here
okay
and what makes this a challenge is
i can
i can tell you some hard truths
um but i want you to acknowledge that
i'm telling you this stuff because i
love you and not because and i care
about you and your marriage not because
i'm just piling on
it's gonna feel like a pile on when
you're listening because i only have if
he was here too i'd be piling on him
right does that make sense so it's not
like i'm picking one over the other so i
only got one here right
um so that's that frames this walk me
through your history so i want to take
him and put him in a box in a drawer and
close the drawer okay
box closed
when did your body
when did you not like what you saw in a
mirror begin
um
probably around
i don't know i feel like
i don't know sophomore year of college i
didn't get the freshman 15 i got the
sophomore 15.
um
so
kind of around that time this is before
that um
i'd be willing to bet my truck's not
very nice but i will be willing to bet
my car this is not about 15 pounds
gained your sophomore year college and
you're 19 and 20 years old
that's correct when did the story that
you didn't look right to begin
i mean i guess who told you
i don't i don't know that anybody told
me that i am currently reading your
newest book and so i know there's like
questions in there about
like was your
family like always on a diet and always
talking about weight and stuff like that
and that is true for me but it wasn't
directed at me it was mostly like my dad
so listen that was always
that well so i said that mean like so
listen i didn't mean to say it like that
um
children absorb their environment
in a mainline fashion
yeah okay
so i am working with a
guy
um
i'm losing weight but not because i
quote unquote need to lose weight i'm
trying to accomplish a particular thing
and so i'm working with
one of the top guys in the in the
country on this
and
i'm also trying to dial in my nutrition
so i'm partnering with
dr norton's helping right so i'm i'm
talking
i have zero
issues with
my aesthetic okay
my son
who's 12
i saw him grabbing parts of his belly
the other day
and he's a cross-country stud he's very
thin
and he started asking questions and i
was like whoa whoa whoa we're cutting
this off right now
okay
because he picks up what's in the air
and mainlines it as though this is him
okay
so whether somebody and this is
important
whether somebody said you don't look
pretty
or you're overweight
which is common right that people are
kids are told that all the time or
you are conscious all con constantly
around people who are always looking in
the mirror saying i don't look good
enough i need to do this we can't go out
here i've got to eat this because i
can't do this i've got to do that
because i can't do this
that that's just what's modeled for you
as you better be careful about what you
look like because that has a direct
correlation to how much and how well and
how deep you're loved
okay
and so in if you if you you mean i've
got there but in the book we talked
about there's stories that you were told
but there's also stories you're born
into
and that 15 pounds may have
and i again i don't want to harp on that
because i think that may be too
simplistic but
it may set off a cascade of
stress response chemicals in your body
that's sounding and start sounding
alarms saying you're not enough well
look out look out look out look out
and then your body begins scanning the
environment for places where you're not
beautiful
places where you're not seeing places
where you're not loved you see what i'm
saying
and then knucklehead
sets off those alarms he sets off a
wildfire with gasoline right
yeah how did you stumble into his
pornography addiction
um
which time
yeah so i mean there's like three
different times
um
so twice when we were dating and then a
third time after we were married um so
the first time was
uh a conversation we were having we were
driving
and
he kind of like
was testing the waters and seeing like
what my reaction would be and so he
asked like so i've known that he like
struggled with it in the past
um and so he kind of like tested the
waters by asking like what would you do
or what would you say
blah blah blah blah that's the most 19
year old way to introduce like so let's
pretend
well yeah we weren't you walked in and
so anyway yeah okay so yeah here's the
thing so you stumbled gail had
conversations about it which led to
another conversation and so and then
here it is right so let's again let's
put him back in the box and back in the
door
okay
when it comes to
quote-unquote body positivity
at the end of the day
i wish it was different than what i'm
about to say
but you're going to have to make a
choice
to look in the mirror and decide
i have value
before and beyond
aesthetics
before external beauty
i am lovable
i am worth being loved
and from the inside out
the words that i say have value and
meaning the things that i think are
funny are actually funny
the
people i like being with are actually
people worth being with
and from that inside out
you then take on a stewardship i'm a
person who stewards their body
i'm a person who takes care of myself
because i'm a person of value it has to
work that direction you can never lose
enough weight to make the inside of
yourself feel okay
yeah right
it's like you can't ever earn enough
money to make yourself feel valuable
you can buy a lot of
a lot of solutions to problems but you
can't solve that inner gnawing right
and so when you start and again you and
i could sit down for a couple hours and
probably peel back a ton of layers on
this onion
you have to decide
and choose i am worth these things
and then you've got to look at your
environment
and it may be that your husband cuts you
off every time you have an idea or he
rolls his eyes and goes we're not going
that way or i don't like that maybe not
maybe he's wonderful
but often body positivity i have found
is linked directly to
the strength and power of my voice
okay in relationship am i hit am i
hitting homer at all or no
yeah somewhat yeah um
i mean definitely making a choice to
decide that i have value before
and beyond what i look like okay
and i also and this is gonna be
controversial but there's a balance
right
there's also i have to look in the
mirror when i got up to 217 pounds
like
i wasn't healthy
yeah right and so i knew
not that i'm not lovable
and not that i'm wholly unattractive
but i knew that i wasn't i wasn't doing
the best for my body and if i don't do
the best for my body i get grumpy and i
get achy and i just want to watch tv
instead of go play with my kids and i
get
self-conscious and let's don't go to the
pool let's don't go to the lake unless
let's just sit at home right so it has
this down it has this ripple effect all
through everything right yeah and so
again that's inside out
and then the stewardship part is well
then cool i'm just gonna start taking
care of my diet i'm gonna start taking
care of moving my body and my body
responds in time
but again that's all secondary and third
and fourth to the inner stuff which is
i'm worth getting up and exercising i'm
worth taking care of myself and the body
positivity comes from the inside out the
second part of this is i don't think
you've gone all in with with this guy
oh
can i ask why yeah or like how
you're either waiting for another shoe
to drop
or you are still
lining yourself up in this imaginary
line of imaginary women and putting
yourself number 76.
yeah
yeah and so um i'll go ahead
well i just want to speak to the first
thing um
so yeah in about a year and a few months
i've had
just recently like we just had this
conversation like a couple of days after
i spent that email like end of june
and like that was the first time
since all of this that i've like been
able to fully trust him for more than a
day okay
[Music]
um
and so
is is it because he's
if you take the pornography off the
table
three different times you've said this
is an important value to me
and he has said
i don't care
and so do you see how this is more about
trust than it is pornography
yes
is is is the value
i want to be your only one
but the part that is rattling your body
is
i've told you what's important to me and
you've blown me off you've said your
needs are more important than mine and
when that's the case in a marriage
the boat sinks
right
and so if you are at a place where you
say i'm going to trust him and by the
way trust is something you practice i'm
going all in
trust is a practice
and there's going to be mornings you
wake up and you suddenly you have a
pang of this or a feeling of that or a
thought of this
and you're going to have to choose i'm
going to trust him
until otherwise noted
so i mean
so the thing on that is like i
like this is the most i've trusted him
in a really long time but i'm scared to
like tell him that i trust him because
i'm scared to fully commit to that
if you don't you will suffocate yourself
and you will drown him
this is a marriage where you've got one
foot in and one foot out
you're playing married
and the problem is is pornography
alcohol
working 98 hours a week
i'm convinced those are connection
issues
and you start trying to heal that gap or
duct tape over it or band-aid over that
gap of disconnection that you both feel
by the way
because he's married to a woman that has
never trusted him
and whether he acknowledges this um
inside or he acknowledges it very
concretely
there's something he thinks is wrong
with him
because she won't trust me
and he might be untrustworthy just with
the pornography discussion you've shown
me him he's proven himself to be
untrustworthy
because he violated your values
see what i'm saying
yeah and so the conversation that needs
to happen with your marriage is are you
in are you out
and right now y'all are scuba diving and
you just have part of the
of the snorkel in
because you're afraid there's like
poison in the tank
and so what you're going to do is you're
going to guarantee
that you suffocate underwater
i mean you drown
by not wanting to breathe in the gas
so what i would tell you is either come
to the surface or
trust that there's oxygen in the tank
and breathe it
yeah
is that fair
yeah yeah
what's the do you trust you
um
i mean i
i do
more than i have
in the past but i
um
yes i think i think so maybe not
completely i just don't want to look
like an idiot if it happens again even
though i know like it has nothing to do
with me
the only way forward is vulnerability
and vulnerable is animals rolling over
and showing their bellies and saying you
could kill me
i'm asking you not to
yeah and i wish that wasn't the case
that's the only way relationships work
yeah and i'd like to think that we were
that way but
i mean i guess not
well
if it makes you feel any better i've had
several times in my 20-year marriage
where i've had to do that
yeah i've had to check and i've realized
oh my gosh i'm not all in anymore
i'm partially in i'm playing a role
and then my wife feels it and then she
has to create a universe where she can
exist in it because i have all the
oxygen and i'm letting most of it go
underwater
see what i'm saying
so the course of marriage is over and
over again
every couple of years every few weeks
every decade
checking yourself and saying whoa whoa
whoa whoa
i'm not all in anymore
i've made work my all-in i've made
protecting my dignity my all in i have
made
not wanting to get burned my all
whatever the thing is i've made that my
all in
but when i got married to you i
committed to us being all in and so i'm
coming back and saying i'm sorry and i'm
going all in
and by the way samantha you're well
within your rights to say
i'm going all in
and if you violate my trust again i'm
gonna go all out
see what i'm saying
yeah
it's the middle ground
that 95 of couples accept as normal
and you look around our culture of
lonely divorced broken up pornography
addicted alcohol addicted netflix
addicted people who are just numbing
their way through a crappy miserable
life
yeah
it's a whole bunch of people scared to
go all in
and there's people who went all in and
got absolutely torched
what i'll tell you that's the only way
forward
okay
i know that's scary
yeah but i feel
more
ready than i ever have good
so here's what that looks like
this is less about what i want and more
about what i need
okay
i would love for you to spend some time
with just samantha just by herself
writing down here's what i need in this
marriage
i need somebody i trust i need somebody
that
when i lay down a value
that they're with me on that
that we are wired together on values
and by the way when it comes something
like pornography
expect your husband to screw up
he may screw up
and that doesn't mean all is lost that
doesn't mean that's the end of
everything and it's
if he comes to you and says hey i
screwed up
that's him making it right
if you church to check his search
history a year from now and all of a
sudden you look at this back then now we
got a problem because it's about the
deception and the lying right and it's
the same if he says hey i have a value
that my wife
my wife is all in
that and fill in the blanket right this
is about y'all creating a life together
one that we can say we're all in on
and that means letting go of this false
security that you have that i'm gonna
keep one toe out i'm gonna keep one i'm
gonna keep myself chained to this thing
and then i'm gonna jump off the edge you
can't do it you gotta just jump
and that's the beauty of relationships
you do it together
and the scary part is you can get hurt
let me put it this way you're gonna get
hurt
[Music]
but man
you know both going together the beauty
on this side of that thing is something
that the alchemy of you all two working
together it can be something so much
greater than you could have ever ever
imagined and for what it's worth you're
worth that
you're worth that
we'll be right back
[Music]
hey what's up now that my new book own
your past change your future is out in
the wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow i'm so
grateful and one of the things i've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past
this book is for everyone in every walk
of life the single 30 year old looking
to sharpen their mind the 25 year old
hoping to make new friends the parent
who's tired of seeing their kids eyes
glued to a screen but who doesn't know
how to re-enter their life people coming
out of abusive relationships
everyone and this book isn't me talking
at you this book is me walking with you
because i've been there too
to better understand and improve your
mental relational and emotional health
please check out own your past change
your future at johndaloni.com today
that's
johndaloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show um
most of y'all don't know this but um
down her arm um kelly has her favorite
country artist tattooed and it's in old
english and it's actually on the back of
her arm and it's keith urban
who would have thought an australian
cowboy living in nashville would make
kelly's heart beat as fast as keith does
but it's true and it's real and um in
honor of where we did fourth of july
this week
[Music]
this is kelly's third favorite song of
all time it's called where the blacktop
ends and it goes like this
gonna kick off my shoes and run and bare
feet and get bug bites all over the
place where the grass and the dirt and
the gravel all meet gonna going back to
the well gonna visit old friends and
feed my soul where the blacktop ends i
like that that's a good song
i'm looking down the barrel of a friday
night riding on a river of freeway
lights goodbye city i'm country bound
till monday rolls around
that's literally how i live my life way
to go kelly hey everybody we'll see you
soon
coming up on the next episode this is
john with the dr john dolone show
greatest mental health podcast ever said
by nobody when you called last time
you've been using a long time right yeah
i had been smoking weed every day for
about eight years tell me about your
adventure you've been on so i have been
sober completely sober for 62 days today
i'm so excited i'm so proud of you i
have a 21 year old daughter who has
recently attempted suicide twice i'd
like to know what we can do as a family
around her to prevent this from
happening again